jeff can we talk about the budget for
frey i understand you financed it
through various jobs
yeah yeah so um i was
i was kind of fortunate after i did the
short film the little experiment for
frey
um we literally wrapped that on the day
that the housing market
and lehman uh collapsed um
which was a terrible time to just spend
your meager savings on a film and then
not have a job for six months um
and so but i was kind of fortunate in a
way that after those six months when
companies started hiring again
they weren't they didn't have the
budgets to go with the big ad agencies
and i had a couple of my fashion clients
that were like well this jeff guy that's
been doing our uh
you know internals in our in-store
videos this stuff's
basically as good as agencies we hire
let's just have him do our commercials
and so i kind of got really lucky um
started
landing a couple of you know i mean they
were hiring me
much less than what they would hire for
a big production company or an
agency but for me it was a lot
and so i was able to put away some
savings
over the course about two years and
um was able to pull it off and then also
just lucky and i wrote it with brian in
mind he and i had done the short film
and we'd known each other a while
knowing you know that i had jaren as my
cinematographer on it who
uh you know obviously is one of the
best cinematographers of this generation
you know i've always felt that way
fortunately it's kind of gotten there
now
um having jody as the producer you know
had a great circle of friends that
brought to life
and then shooting in oregon was a huge
help too um
you know it was a lot of people there
one they believed in the story
um they really believed in what we were
trying to do with it so we got
um you know uh we got people all the
all the cars for the film were donated
to us
uh all the locations with the exception
of two we got for free we got the wood
mill for free
we just had to have insurance um
you know just so much you're able to get
and people were so
helpful with it uh the employment agency
seen actually when we were
talking to women who owned that actual
employment agency
she said that if we needed extras she
would reach out to her
network of uh people who were looking
for
work so that's how you're able to get so
many extras for the film
it was just yeah so in terms like
pulling it off for a smaller
budget it was um
it just took a lot of favors but on
you know like i said because of that
commercial world
you know was our budget on that was
probably the craft services budget for
like an a24 film
um but it was still enough that we were
able to pull off something with all
those
all those other people really putting
their heart and soul into it
and one of my proudest things about that
was
so many of the local people that worked
on it it did end up elevating their
careers some of them was their first
film they'd ever worked on
and you know i wrote everybody a letter
recommendation for whatever they wanted
to do because i'm like
if you worked on this film you had your
hands in every department so
um i mean there were there were entire
days where was literally
myself jaron uh brian another whoever
the other actor was and matt who was a
pa
like that was the entirety of our
production it was just you know it was
three people and two actors or three
actors at a time
for days on end so you know everybody on
it just put in so much
and so they a lot of their careers got
elevated by it which was
so great to see because we've all worked
on
no budget films that when we're done
with like well that was a waste of three
days or
five days or whatever so knowing that
the people that came on board were able
to go on and do
more afterwards and were elevated by
this film was just
something i was really proud of as well
because
it's a hard industry so being able to
help lift others up
is a good feeling so you knew how much
you had in this
bank account or bank accounts or
whatever when when you started to dip
past a certain point and and maybe the
clock was ticking
what was your mindset uh
um i when
when the funds were running low it was
uh it was nerve-racking had
compartmentalized because the
the anxiety meltdown that was happening
just put that in this box over here
and this box over here is like well if
you don't finish the film then you just
ruined your life for nothing
so um it was and uh
we actually had we took a three-day
hiatus because i had a client that
wanted me to do a commercial
a little web commercial it was like yeah
we'll put on hiatus i
literally took the last of the money i
had and gave it to
jaron who was stuck in portland for
three days um
while i was away and uh you know
basically went back to new york did a
shoot
and flew right back um i didn't get paid
for it for another month but at least
had that coming in and then
really grateful uh marissa the lead
actress in it her parents
gave i should remember this i think it
was two thousand dollars to us to help
out
um my own parents threw in a thousand
dollars
and helped cover some of the hotel costs
for us
so you know it was fortunate like family
and friends really pitched in
my girlfriend at the time kim she set up
a paypal account where people could make
donations that helped bring a couple
hundred more dollars in
um just really just crawled across the
finish line
and uh and then when i when we wrapped
you know got back to new york
and just took like the next three months
just doing as much client work as i
could because
um i wasn't gonna have a home for much
longer if i didn't
and uh i didn't want art to uh or life
to imitate art that much
so so it sounds like it was kind of
rah-rah out of the gate and then
piecemeal at the end it was that's kind
of how you finished it
yeah it was i mean definitely we knew i
mean the budget
was so small and i guess at this point i
can say i mean we literally went into
this shoot with just over twenty
thousand dollars
um obviously we spent a lot more over
the course of the film but that was what
we're starting with on it
and uh that's not a lot
that doesn't stretch very far when
you're trying to when you've got to fly
some cast and crew out to new york and
house them and feed them
or out from new york to oregon housing
feed them
transportation logistical costs and uh
you know just some other checks would
come in from
projects i'd done a few months before
add that to the budget
and again my girlfriend at the time kim
she was managing uh
managing all the finances she would
watch my bank account and tell me where
i was at
and she'd be like you guys need to spend
less money on coffee
like i can't that's
that's not a compromise we can make
right especially not in oregon
no i don't know the coffee are they
comparable to yeah seattle yeah
yeah um there was a place uh that we
were just hooked on and
brian still talked about to this day
he's like i just i want to go back for
their coffee
um yeah it was uh it was intense
that's for sure uh every dollar on that
one mattered i mean all the
wardrobe that we bought came from
goodwill uh
you know again and just every favor we
could get was
uh was a was just
essential i mean if we hadn't gotten all
the favors we had gotten there's no way
that film would have happened
so and sorry you shot right before the
actual quote-unquote meltdown the limo
brothers
that was the short film uh poor the one
that he does an experiment for fray
uh so that was right before that
meltdown so i guess i was ahead of the
curve in terms of talking about uh
you know just financial precarity uh and
obviously it inspired the script uh
in this one you know thus why marisa's
character is a teacher of uh
morals and uh economics um
uh i forget the specific term which is
terrible but uh but yeah so
you know wedge that in there in terms of
as a way to discuss some of those
higher ideas without being too
heavy-handed i hope
um but yeah i was definitely heavily
inspired by that
because you know it's just it's so easy
to fall through the cracks as an artist
i've seen it you know as a freelancer
and an artist
you know it's feast or famine sometimes
things are great and then
you know buy a new set of lenses and
then you don't get a job for six months
you're like oh god that was a stupid
choice
and so you know i know how easy it is
and granted for me a lot of those
financial decisions are
not essentials a set of lenses isn't an
essential it's a good business
investment
i mean i've used the same set of lenses
now for
six seven years and they're gorgeous um
uh staying with camera you know drop 20
30 grand on a camera
that's a lot of money that's you know
it's a new car for
a nice new car and all that but
that pays itself back over time yet
those are still expenses that are huge
and
you know you hit a dry spell with work
and you're like oh god i'm not gonna be
able to make rent now
so those are all things that i took from
my experiences over the years and try to
work into it and make it feel authentic
you know i
i can see how somebody could easily just
tire of the rat race and just that
constant trying to keep your head above
water
and just step out like i'm just i'm
gonna go live in the woods
i'm gonna go sleep under a bridge i'm
not gonna stress it
there's actually there's even a homeless
gentleman who slipped my subway station
that every now and then i'd
come home with a bottle of wine or a
bottle of whiskey or something like that
and we'd sit on the
bench on the subway platform and just
chat and he was that way
he said he just got tired of trying to
survive because he's like
this isn't an easy life but at least i
don't have the
i don't have the worries that i had and
so wanted to bring that to it it's just
that idea of
the struggle just the day-to-day
struggle that so many people
face and don't have a way out of i feel
so fortunate that as a filmmaker that i
can go and do a commercial
and live off of that for a month or two
or three months
and then go back to my writing and my
editing and stuff like that like that's
such a luxury to be able to have that
that most people don't have
that ability to get that magical check
that's what the lottery's
so popular for um and so
yeah i just wanted to try and express
that in a in a film and show
show to people who may be a little bit
more fortunate that it's really easy for
people to
to lose their grip and give up hope